hi everyone I'm Laureen and imed Angeles
it's like god I think they used to you
being on a strained by now today we're
playing the forest which is currently in
alpha it just got released last month so
it's an open world survival horror game
what do you play as a person in a forest
okay yeah granted we don't know a lot
about this game I haven't played it more
than like 10 minutes or so so this will
be a nice learning experience oh I'm in
an airplane oh he's holding my arm
seeing off me strange China Sea raised
position hey look some guys much hatake
gonna take care of him see it ain't
worried he's a nice game ah she died
didn't she got axed um oh dude hey come
on Christ see if you can just remember
the leg I guess is important check out
backpack for a second let's see oh it's
like when I like it's a nice spread I
like I like that you can see your feet
any first person game where you can see
your feet it's a tick in my book flag
dance style pick up everything that you
come across in the first 10 minutes oh
god I'm headless so funny oh wow that's
awesome so you got a tennis ball I'm
guessing that might be good for
distraction oops I didn't have it
anymore I mean a plane just crashed and
all this [ __ ] where his other TSA
handles your baggage okay let's get down
a tree it's gonna be sweet check this
out this is awesome holy crap it's in it
just like oh oh that's the best look in
the distance turn around turn around 180
180 what whoa how did you know that
because I sold I saw the movie I don't
know what the eighth okay oh wow we
haven't died yet so I'm pretty happy
with our progress our shelter is made
okay
here we go yeah it's taking it out of my
inventory that's a really neat all right
let's chop some trees down yeah I can
hmm I'm getting awfully hungry yeah oh
that bird got all up in my face iguana
sorry it's either you and me buddy so
gave us life these RV let's go find
movie use is that how I kept leaves
light it yeah bic lighters that's pretty
good case you wanted to pimp out your
place dude who can who builds a cabin is
right out of there like nothing it only
takes 35 loads in 14 sticks it's a
pretty good deal I know I just have to
chop down every single show you around
here and then i'll have enough logs
build a cab you just walked into the
fire lit bella in chat suggests building
a blu-ray player i kin z z catch some
Z's okay alright so early morning good
now I still got a good fire fight people
for our children matt is a bird on our
house that nice it's like Mary Poppins
except you have an axe and you're a
sociopath how do i cook the phone okay
see oh look it's cooking Edmund that's
very good screen along hold on you can
keep your logs in place that's awesome
what the [ __ ] is that seriously that
looks like looking out of a girl pakka
game 50 huts in the distance they look
like it oh my rabbits still like okay
imma fine it's gonna burn this is a good
is intriguing hey people and there's men
just looking at us try and suck around
back and sneak up on him with anything
why because that's how you do that's how
you do stealth takedowns Jesus play
video games wats what are you killing a
friendly person I think I should
approach him from the front I wouldn't
want someone to sneak up there if there
is a bigot will sneak up to them and if
he there isn't like a talk
action that pops up we acts in the head
alright um friendly friendly you
friendly it's called like a weapon I
made out of hand I can tease my blood
rain I don't wanna look at this guy's
blood so you should axe him in the back
of it I'm gonna kill him he's done
anything to us oh you're too nice you
should never play dayz everyone telling
you to ax him and mary says you're way
too nice to survive in this game and too
nice to survive in life I would say oh
god why all those balls bouncing all
over cited let's get a good look at the
face say all right I'm glad we did this
just predict you so pretend that's your
high school friend high school best
buddy and just pretend that that guy
strong his or her face up like that now
don't run out to him stop it well my god
okay well we're going well okay don't
stop jig jig I can eat for juki don't
app don't oh oh holy crap okay seven
awesome this is this a good progress
where'd he go early okay where's the
head I need the head seems like a waste
that's okay we'll just find his friends
and family and then now I feel bad Oh
awesome the moral the stories the real
horror is mankind I can't leave a stole
all these tennis balls was it were like
tennis camp or something there are so
many tennis balls in this game more
tennis ball soon I mean it's annoying
cause like when I'm carrying your tennis
ball I can't put it in my pocket oh yeah
I just have to hold you YUM you haven't
crossed the tennis shorts yet mmm i
think the point of these effigies is to
scare them off right yeah so why there
enjoy your eyes oh Jesus Christ oh Jesus
Oscar very good oh he does oh I like the
I like the crouching while you swing for
more distance oh Jesus you just rocket
John to there it's awesome yeah it lands
on I got too many limbs okay um me set
up energy we need three hands yeah
depends let's see if we can use a leg as
a fighting tool oh my yeah he's alright
that's curse oh man that guy needed a
pity really bad can just use the head
and just like three oh my god actually
yeah do it oh oh no oh wait I can scale
cliffs I forgot not that clever wait a
minutes she serious this guy's amazing
oh oh no did he die for real I almost
died what happens now I've got all my
stuff still yeah I get your ax that's
pretty good recipe Jones says two times
you end up in the cave up to you quote
unquote died how about I just swing my
axe forward as I go stay away I'm gonna
swing my axe if you run into it's not my
fault you're going to watch the house
icons I'm gonna assume that that's oh
hey oh okay spin foot forward yeah you
overwhelm you should run I'm running let
me out yeah they don't think of having
fun so I'm just gonna leave them we will
name they can make fire that means
they're intelligent and now they see use
each woman warrior they don't see yeah I
think yeah Oh balls he got me one hit
kill a survivor three no he's told me
now okay all right let's do this alright
scavenge the crap out of this plane
BioShock Infinite style Jesus and oh my
god what are you holding am I gonna rock
oh my god you can equip a rock yeah oh
man I never got to eat that rapid that
ipod so hunger oh I see movement over
there
running across they should I put my
shelter right here while they walk
towards me I know I don't think that's
good okay I'm glad you're here it's for
them you're outnumbered I was mom and
dad and two kids content say like okay
there's another family of cannibals on
the other side of this life this must be
like the cannibal town so say family say
like call me or something no out to kill
you these guys just want to survive just
like me is he just sleeping nope not
anymore yeah this is where the cannibals
live so I wouldn't build a ship yeah and
this was me in real life can you like
can you hack up the so so than like this
mess oh yeah its bearing their town
where you gonna live now huh okay shelta
temporary shelter hunting shelter all
these different types I'll fill the log
cabin 35 vlogs gonna do a lot of
shopping it's all right you can do it in
time you think you should totally do it
you're golden come on Kevin all right to
it we have to try again once there we go
all right let's get to work what's gonna
fall on the cabin Oh God oh all right
how long have this access to your
ability I'd sure not I need a bigger
acts all about flip sick it's all right
oh man it's shaping up real good oh yes
getting sick this is a gwan applying on
the tree got that train my god my train
you're heartless man it'll just live in
its life chillin on the street so my
treatment sorry we really got 75 look
left to go Kelly we're doing this but
that's a big tree we need to get fun
okay you're like 60 ones out of this is
still on Lyons says that they enjoy tree
chops yeah this is the stream for you
all I got every time I come in house far
as it's never terrified we just end up
doing stupid [ __ ] like this here we go
don't worry this miracle tree go on us
yeah okay
I know logically speaking this can't
hurt us at all wait is that a body oh
[ __ ] he was living in that tree let me
shop man make it a tree fell on him if
you're just standing around I'm gonna
use his arms to build a log cabin okay I
guess coming looking for his friend the
stroke and fill all witnesses come here
are you you weren't fast enough he has
the signage Dino faced bastard there you
go give me a Faro can you take her uh-oh
you put the fire out oh whoa rocky Jones
Oh what happened there was awesome you
fell into the sky fall into the sky okay
enough see what you know the cave great
was excellent oh ok oh well this is a
pleasant so we gotta go back to building
on cabins I'll see you guys later I see
daylight out there so this is going well
how far could we possibly be from our
log cabin is that it in the distance I
think that's actually is it oh thank god
okay so we built on Kevin right next to
the cave of mutants good plan and back
to what we were doing the important
thing
how do we get that log up there now it's
going to BES house alrighty and in the
future we'll know where we live because
oh Jesus he's got a little hat from your
hat I don't think that's a half Oh what
oh no it's happening again no no that
was the forest for those of you who are
watching that is now oh it's got some
really cool ideas I think I could yeah I
think once I self legend goes out yeah
definitely as usual let us know what
she's all about the stream in the
comments below or on the HOH love
hashtag on twitch a Twitter and on
twitch I guess if you want to let us
know right now we'll be back again next
week at the same time and just will be
back as well thanks for joining us thank
you everyone bye week